Speaker 1: There is a legal expert, Norm Eisen.
Who believes at this point without a doubt that
Donald Trump is heading towards an indictment
and that Trump's allies have started to relieve
to receive target letters, which
are different. Then we want you to
testify. Target letters are you are actually
a target in this investigation. Let's discuss
with the caveat that great until Trump
is actually charged, I remain skeptical
that anything's going to happen. Newsweek
Report Trump heading towards an indictment
as Allies Receive Warnings. Attorney Norman
Eisen predicted Friday that former President
Donald Trump is heading towards an indictment in
Georgia after some of his allies there received
so-called target letters from the Fulton County
DA's office. Now, I want to remind everybody.
A month ago, maybe six weeks ago, I said that
I don't think charges against Trump are likely.
But if there are going to be charges, I believe
the likeliest source is the investigation in
Georgia where there was so much evidence, recorded
evidence, phone calls, pressure campaigns,
back channels, trying to get specific Georgia
officials. This wasn't just, oh, I went on the
news and said I won, or we held a hearing where
Rudy Giuliani had flatulence and also, you know,
said that I won. This was specific phone
calls. This was targeting Brad Raffensperger.
This was sending Lindsey Graham deputizing Lindsey
Graham to go in and say, well, can't we look at it
and see if maybe we can do something, find
a different conclusion? I believe that the
most likely source of charges would be Georgia,
and that is indeed what normalizing is saying.
The Georgia County D.A., Fanny Willis, launched
the investigation into Trump early last year
after he pressured officials in the state to help
overturn President Joe Biden's election win. That
effort drew national attention after audio of a
call between Trump and Georgia Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger leaked in which Trump urged
him to find enough votes to change the outcome.
Yahoo News first reported Friday that David
Shafer, the state Republican chair in Georgia,
and state senators Bert Jones and Brandon Beech
have received target letters from Willis, warning
they could face indictment in connection to her
investigation. Jeff DeSantis, a spokesperson
for the D.A., also said Willis is considering
subpoenaing Trump to testify before the special
grand jury convened for the probe. Isan said to
the New York Times, I do believe that the great
likelihood is he's heading towards an indictment.
The legal expert previously served as special
counsel to the House Judiciary during Trump's
first impeachment. There is powerful proof of
violations of Georgia law in the form of the
smoking gun tape of him demanding 11,780 votes
when it is perfectly clear from the tape that
he knows the votes don't exist. Yes, and that
is an important point. Some have very meekly and
placidly and not credibly tried to defend Trump's
request for 11,780 votes by saying he's not saying
fraudulently get me those votes. He's just saying,
I believe I really won. It's not that big of a gap
to overcome. Let's find legal votes. Anyone who
has listened to that tape knows that that is not
at all what he was trying to say. So. Fascinating.
Interesting. The news headlines for the last three
years have been Trump is heading to an indictment.
Personally, I know people convinced that Donald
Trump is going to be charged and we may see
headlines for the next six months saying any day
now, any day now, Trump's going to be charged.
If it happens, I will be the first to tell
you. I am not confident that that's going
to take place. Now, one other thing, and
I want to think ahead here a little bit,
because this is another important issue.
Imagine Trump gets indicted. Okay.
Imagine that the indictment goes to trial.
Unlikely. But imagine we get through those
two steps. Imagine that there is a jury trial. How
do you get a jury that will be able to properly
and fairly adjudicate a Donald Trump case?
If you have one Trump cultist on the jury,
you have a hung jury. How do you even do jury
selection? I mean, think about it. How do you
find someone who has no opinion about Trump and no
significant preconceived notions of of his guilt
or innocence? And then the next layer is, if you
think about there are nonpolitical people. There
are people who know nothing and care nothing about
who's president. They just don't pay attention.
But are those people we trust to be in the
position of even adjudicating the case?
Think about people you know, who have no idea
what has gone on the last six years. Are those
people that we would be confident saying this is
a jury of our peers and they will adjudicate? This
doesn't seem like it to me. So that's sort
of like a second order issue if we ever got
an indictment and had to pick a jury. But we'll
deal with that later. Norm Eisen says Trump is
heading towards an indictment and at least to some
degree, Trump must think it's possible because
the report from Rolling Stone is he plans to run
for 24. And it's to keep himself out of prison,
essentially away from criminal charges as
he sees it. What do you expect? Let me know.